welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of The Last
of Us episode 4 the next episode trailer
I don't know how we're gonna move on
after that bill and Frank episode but
you know the story is called The Last of
Us and there are more survivors to
follow into this horrible horrible
nightmare but you know just to ease your
pain that painting that I thought showed
Joel is actually a rendition of a photo
of a slightly younger but every bit is
sexy Murray Bartlett from the HBO series
looking how about you I feel better now
so I think we can move on and thanks to
grammarly for sponsoring this video more
on them later this next episode promo
doesn't give much away but there are
some really important details that you
might have missed that can help us
connect the dots to show the major ways
this HBO series is gonna diverge from
the games and just some deeper
post-apocalyptic World details to unpack
also a reminder to subscribe to our new
channel the Deep dive launching February
17th and we have a channel trailer
coming this week to give you an idea of
the amazing content we are working on so
subscribe at Deep dive INR and hit that
notification Bell so that you will see
it first because I know with the
comments all of you love to be first
first first okay let's check out this
episode 4 trailer foreign
it's nice I'm all turned around don't
look at the state map this is my second
day
okay so after leaving Bill and franks in
Bill's Truck with that recharge truck
battery Joel and Ellie are spending some
time camping in the woods why not just
sleep in the car on the roadside well
that's how you get found and killed by
some roving gangs like many children
whose taste buds resist anything that
ain't buttered skinny Ellie hates the
smell of coffee and Joel slurps it just
to spite her remember in the qz things
like coffee would be particularly
difficult to come by Smugglers like Joel
and Tess couldn't even get chicken so he
must be really enjoying some of Bill's
coffee Supply now look at Ellie's road
map there is a red mark in the middle of
Western Pennsylvania not exactly on
Pittsburgh which would be right left at
Mark Pittsburgh is pretty much south of
Erie Pennsylvania Erie being along the
coast of Lake Erie so it actually looks
like they're taking 70 West Beyond
Pittsburgh actually I'm mentioning
Pittsburgh because the next stage of the
game would take you to Pittsburgh after
leaving bills but I have a feeling this
series is going to alter the geography
more on that in a bit now even if you
don't have a writing job you're gonna
have to write an email a slack message
or something along those lines and it's
important to feel confident that your
message sounds perfect and the way you
want it to when you send it off well
grammarly can help with that grammar
leads communication assistance can help
with everything from comprehensive
spelling to grammar all the way to tone
the main thing I do after I send an
email is worry about whether I was too
direct or too polite too weird or I
don't know it's some kind of
communication anxiety there and you'll
get the picture the gram release premium
competent tone suggestions ensure that I
come across as confident capable and
sure it helps me to be less wishy-washy
when I'm trying to Wrangle everybody for
a meeting or keep that meeting tight so
I can make it to a movie screening
that's a big positive your tone matters
especially when you're working with
multiple colleagues building those
strong work relationships with a
confident tone will help you move your
projects along and get your work done on
time grammarly works where you work so
it's easy to incorporate into your daily
life it seamlessly integrates into apps
like Google Docs and Microsoft Word the
right tone can move your projects
forward with the help of grammarly go to
grammarly.com new rockstars to sign up
for an account and if you'd like to
level up your writing and tone upgrade
to grammarly premium for 20 off Joe and
Ellie's drives past the train bridge
that has collapsed the train car in the
end dangling over the side I'm curious
to know what happened here because it
sounds like it only took a couple weeks
in September 2003 for the infection to
Wipeout most of everyone and I think
that would have been too soon for the
infrastructure to collapse like this and
even if the train got overridden by
infected people like what we assume
happened on the plane that we saw last
episode the whole Bridge wouldn't
collapsed to meet the train like this so
two options I see here a some folks try
to activate the train years after
outbreak day to get somewhere and the
bridge didn't hold up and if so I would
love to see that story someday or B
shortly after the outbreak day some
folks were traveling by train and there
was a fear that they might be infected
so the government bombed this bridge as
they were crossing it and if so I also
really want to see that story someday
Joel and Ellie get lost in a city where
a guy asks for help Joel sees or it's
our trap and pulls away but runs over a
nail strip and they crash I think the
city is actually Kansas City this ruined
boarded up town where spray painted
militia trucks Patrol looks a lot like
the one we saw in the trailer where Joel
and Ellie were hiding from the those
trucks behind a car and on that car's
license plate it is a Kansas license
plate with a Wy that stands for
Wyandotte County on Kansas plates we
actually see that same car in this same
street later in this episode 4 trailer
and this trailer also shows Melanie
lynskey's character named Kathleen who's
a new character to the story reported to
be the leader of a Kansas City
revolutionary Movement by the way I love
seeing Linsky in this role especially
since she's now playing a post
survivalist in former cannibal on
Yellowjackets but it's hard to tell from
Ellie's map when they're lost in the
city I think though it might be Kansas
City and that would be the reason Joel
says to look at the city map and not a
state map because this city sits on the
border of Missouri in Kansas and so the
Kansas parts of the city wouldn't appear
on a map of Missouri and vice versa
let's move on to the rest of the trailer
this has gone too far it has to stop
where is he
we'll get through this
I know
okay here we see more of the Kansas City
revolutionary movement trucks with a
plow with the word run painted on it
this trailer and the preseason trailer
showed some armed soldiers this militia
kicking indoors going house to house
there was also in that preseason trailer
a truck with we the people painted on
the side of it and the fedra logo X out
so yeah this group is not Pedra some
group fighting Vedra like the fireflies
but not the fireflies exactly and this
group has successfully taken over Kansas
City we see Joel walking through a
roadblock while nearby an ambulance a
school bus and a city bus have all been
left abandoned and an unknown man Becks
for his light to catch Lane as she holds
a gun to his head as she asks where is
he now Neil druckman and Craig Mason
confirmed that Kathleen is a new
character a leader of a group of hunters
from the game they're probably referring
to the hunter gang that takes over
Pittsburgh in the game after
overthrowing Pedro a group that had even
turned on Firefly agitators these guys
are some real it just looks
like the series has taken everything
that happens in Pittsburgh in the game
instead relocates it all to Kansas City
why are they doing this well maybe it's
a geographical timeline question like
they wanted to move Joel and Ellie
halfway across the country at this stage
of their Journey maybe shooting in
Kansas city was easier than shooting in
Pittsburgh but the two most memorable
characters from Pittsburgh in the game
are the brothers Henry and Sam and we
know the characters are going to be in
Kansas City in the show I'm not spoiling
anything HBO actually confirmed this in
a press release last summer which lists
that the two boys are in hiding from
this revolutionary movement in Kansas
City maybe these are the ones Kathleen
is looking for but why is she looking
for them so the preseason trailer shots
of Joel and Ellie with Henry and Sam in
a location covered in drawings of Castle
yeah probably Henry and Sam's Hideout as
well as the shot of the two brothers
hugging in this episode 4 trailer Joel
takes the butt of a gun and uppercuts a
kid with a shotgun in a laundromat a
good shotgun goes off and this trailer
ends with Joel saying they'll get
through this and Ellie's saying I know
which of course is Han Solo or I love
you but Ellie being confident that Joel
will get them through this just shows
that she knows they're capable of taking
care of each other better than anyone
else is trying to kill them Ellie may be
naive but that blind optimism is really
what Joel needs to move forward at this
stage oh by the way I have been wearing
Joel's iconic Flint in Tinder wax canvas
trucker jacket from huckberry you can
buy your own from huckberry by clicking
the link in the description to support
new Rockstar's last coverage and a
reminder to subscribe to the Deep dive
and follow me on Instagram and Twitter
at eavos holiday new rockstars And
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]